nope
what do you think
[Music]
that's right before we get into the meat
of today's video let's talk about
today's sponsor hellofresh hellofresh is
a meal kit company that delivers fresh
quality produce from the farm to your
door in less than a week allowing you to
savor summer flavors right from home
with over 30 dinner recipes to choose
from every week hellofresh offers more
choices than any meal kit the best part
is all of these meals can be made in
around 30 minutes or less this week I've
been delivered barbecue chicken
sandwiches which I'm making here with a
diverse menu like theirs you really
can't go wrong even with picky eaters
hellofresh even offers veggie
pescetarian and fit and wholesome meals
to make it easy to stick to your goals I
think even Helga Hufflepuff would
approve if you're like me and you value
saving time and eating well then I
highly recommend you give hellofresh a
try today you can do just that for free
just go to hellofresh.com and use code
Harry Potter Theory 16 for up to 16 free
meals and 3 surprise gifts so what are
you waiting for again that's 16 free
meals and three surprise gifts if you
visit hellofresh.com and use the code
Harry Potter Theory 16. let's get into
it
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory have
you ever wondered how spells are created
well the answer is simpler than you
might have guessed
it's all thanks to a handful of
extremely cunning witches and wizards
who saw a problem in their life and
tried to create a magical solution
as we look through the historical
records of The Wizarding World we find
no shortage of famous Wizards and
witches who have left their mark on
Magic and created spells that are still
in use in modern times today we're going
to take a look at some of the most
famous spells and their creators as we
go over the history of magical inventors
let's get into it but dear Ali and Ben
copper Ben copper and his friend Padilla
Ali were both students at Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry in the
mid-1980s although copper was sorted
into Gryffindor and Ali into house
Ravenclaw the two ended up creating a
spell together this particular magical
attack was an updated version of the
traditional knockback Jinx that the
students at Hogwarts had used for
Generations named flippendo Maxima due
to its greater effects this particular
spell might have actually been quite
dangerous for the students since it
caused them to fall backwards and
oftentimes their heads would bounce
violently off the stone floors of the
school at a different time during her
stay at Hogwarts bedia Ali created
another spell this one summoned a
dazzling meteor shower in the sky and as
Ali would later come to discover she
could even use the incantation to
transform the paintings at Hogwarts and
filled them with their own falling stars
William Weasley William Weasley was the
oldest member of the Weasley siblings
his job as a curse breaker often took
him far away from the Weasley's family
home known as the borough during his
time away Bill used his magical
abilities to become one of gringott's
greatest employees in a showdown in
Egypt Bill even defeated a mummy but
perhaps the greatest achievement came
during the second Wizarding War during
that time Bill invented a spell that
would block any dark mark wearing Death
Eater from entering a building this
barrier would become pivotal in the
battles that the Order of the Phoenix
would participate in throughout the war
Severus Snape as a former Death Eater
and a member of the Order of the Phoenix
Severus Snape LED an interesting life
and in addition to his many missions in
service to Albus Dumbledore Snape was
actually quite an accomplished spell
maker during his time as a student in
Hogwarts and as a Professor Snape
created many of these spells that
students use to this day Snape's
langlook curse was a particular popular
one with a simple swing of a wand this
spell would lock a target's tongue to
the roof of their mouth preventing them
from speaking as a frequent victim of
bullying Snape undoubtedly found this
spell useful when he was on the
receiving end of jeers in the same vein
Snape also created a spell that would
cause anyone nearby to temporarily
experience a deafening noise so that he
could gossip without fear of being
overheard this Bell was called the
muffliato charm and Harry Potter often
used class but perhaps Snape's most
famous curse was sectum sempra this one
caused painful cuts to magically appear
on its victim's skin
Harry used it in fights against Draco
Malfoy the inferi who protected one of
Voldemort's horcruxes and even against
its creator Severus Snape himself
gilderoy Lockhart Professor gilderoy
Lockhart's Legacy isn't one to be very
proud of on his journey to eventually
becoming a star teacher at Hogwarts
Lockhart had regularly exaggerated his
own abilities and even lied about his
achievements he was famously exposed as
a fraud when confronted by Harry Potter
and Ron Weasley shortly before the pair
entered the Chamber of Secrets
unfortunately in the aftermath Lockhart
erased his own memory but before his
downfall gilderoy Lockhart actually
created one of the most charmingly
narcissistic spells in The Wizarding
World through an incantation Lockhart
was able to project His Image into the
sky via the holographic spell so that
everyone around could enjoy his Beauty
Albus Dumbledore we can't be sure how
many spells Albus Dumbledore created but
according to the record of Hogwarts
there's only one that was attributed to
him this was the Patronus charm a
Communications Bell during the second
Wizarding War Dumbledore smartly
realized there were too many ways that
the Order of the Phoenix could be
deceived and to be lured into traps by
false messages to combat this he created
a spell that would use an individual's
Patronus to transmit messages since this
was always unique to a non-dark wizard
Tom Riddle Tom Riddle more famously
known as Lord Voldemort was an extremely
accomplished spellcrafter before his
resurrection riddle created more Mort
the spell that set the sky alight with
the dark mark and he even designed the
spell that would kill Albus Dumbledore
the curse that rested on the Ring of
marvelo gaunt yes Dumbledore died too of
ADA cadavra but this spell would have
killed him Tom Riddle also created a
spell that allowed him to fly without
the use of a mount or prum this was
called unsupported flight and although
the films depict many Death Eaters
achieving a similar feat it was actually
quite rare it was a technique that
Wizards and witches had spent centuries
trying to master and it wasn't until Tom
Riddle's discovery that it was finally
perfected basil Horton and Randolph
Keach basil Horton and Randolph Keach
were a pair of famous quidditch players
but they were more than just a pair of
Falmouth members of the Falmouth Falcons
they were also the creators of the Comet
Trading Company you might recognize this
name because it's responsible for some
of the most famous broomstick models in
production well Horton teaches Comet
broomsticks were so beloved by quidditch
players for their incredible speed and
also their sudden stopping Precision
this was actually achieved by a spell
that the pair of Founders created known
as the breaking charm it allowed their
broomsticks to stop on a dime and was
also quite safe Miranda goshawk over 50
years before Harry Potter's final
showdown against Lord Voldemort a young
witch named Miranda goshawk created a
pretty gross spell Miranda's goal was
simple she wanted her older siblings to
finally listen to her and stop walking
all over her to do this Miranda created
the bat bogey hex which transformed her
Target's boogers into disgusting
bat-like creatures thanks to its
revolting nature the hex was massively
popular among students at Hogwarts at
one point a student from an unknown
house actually used the hex to cause
bats to fly out of every member of his
classes nose Lavina monk Stanley Lavina
monk Stanley was a witch who lived
hundreds of years before the rise of
Lord Voldemort during her life as an
unspeakable in the department of
mysteries in the 18th century Lavina
spent her time surrounded by the unknown
her job dealt with the mysteries of
death time love and Consciousness but
that wasn't quite enough for her monk
Stanley also decided to create her own
spells she was the witch responsible for
the Wonder lighting charm which caused a
wizard one tip to cast a bluish light
she also created the opposite spell the
one extinguishing charm which
essentially turned the light off Elliot
smethwick a decade or two before basil
Horton and Randolph Keach created the
comic broomstick company a wizard named
Elliot smathwick made an important
contribution to broomstick riding
realizing that the devices were quite
uncomfortable to ride Elliot created the
cushioning charm which would create a
magical seat wherever a rider sat Daisy
penafold like many other quidditch
players and fans Daisy penafold was a
witch who used her expert skills as a
spellcaster to create a charm for the
sport her slowing charm was used to stop
quaffles from falling straight to the
ground and instead made them slowly
descend so that quidditch players didn't
need to slow down the pace of the game
by grabbing the balls from the pitch
orabella Nutley The Mending charm has
been shown to be quite a versatile piece
of magic if used properly the
incantation is able to repair almost any
inanimate object that has been broken
but the spell surprisingly isn't even
that old it was created by a witch named
orabella Nutley only a few hundred years
before the rise of Lord Voldemort's
Nutley who was employed by the ministry
of magic used the spell in the aftermath
of an incident the Colosseum in Rome
where she was forced to repair the
Millennia old building urquhart
raccarrow erkhart raccarrow was an
accomplished healer in The Wizarding
community and lived in the mid 17th
century although you might suspect that
much of the Wizarding World like that of
Muggles suffered from a lack of
sophisticated medicine you'd be wrong
Wizards and witches had almost always
been exceptional healers and were able
to cure almost any mortal malady that
they were Afflicted with so when we look
at rakhara's most famous spell the
entrail expelling curse it's hard to
figure out exactly what the healthcare
provider was trying to achieve some
thought this spell literally caused a
target's colon to be ripped from their
inside sides and drawn out of their body
but rakharo as we've already mentioned
wasn't a dark wizard of any type he
wouldn't have used the charm to cause
harm so in all actuality the spell
probably just alleviates the symptoms of
constipation in its Target although the
students of Hogwarts probably didn't
waste time using it with ill intent
herpa the fowl herpa the foul might have
been the most powerful dark wizard of
the ancient world any Wizarding
historian would tell you that herpo was
a terrible Sorcerer And would probably
point to his creation of the Basilisk as
his most horrifying contribution to
Magic but there was one more thing that
he made that might have been even worse
it was herpo who devised a way to
fracture a soul and preserve it in
physical objects so that dark wizard
could unnaturally prolong their life
this was the spell that Tom Riddle would
use to survive his first death and it
was Tom Riddle's horcruxes that would
ultimately take Alba Dumbledore's life
and that's it for this video do you want
a part two there are still more witches
and wizards to cover let me know in the
comments until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live